la mort de joël le theule les obsèques
du ministre de la défense auront lieu
mardi
arrivé à paris du premier ministre du
québec rené lévesque et qu'un le
successeur de marc au wac open quitte la
présidence du parti chinois
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir monsieur
joël le theule ministre de la défense
est décédé l'année dernière une crise
cardiaque il avait 50
il était célibataire il est mort à sablé
sur sarthe dont il était le maire depuis
longtemps monsieur le theule avait été
plusieurs fois ministre dans les
gouvernements pompidou couve de murville
et raymonde à ces images seront les
dernières images publiques de joël le
theule le ministre de la défense
recevait hier dans sa bile sablé sur
sarthe le ministre des universités
madame soigner ses hits et ce n'est que
quelques heures plus tard que joël le
theule ressentaient les premiers
symptômes du mal qui devait l'emporter
agrégé de géographie monsieur le theule
avait commencé sa carrière dans
l'enseignement au prytanée militaire de
la flèche
mais vite la politique n'intéresse en
1958 au retour du général de gaulle il
se présente à la députation dans la
sarthe sous l'étiquette fn est il sera
constamment réélu de même qu'il sera
toujours réussi maire de sablé depuis
toujours jor-el l'hôtel s'était
passionné pour les problèmes de défense
notamment à l'assemblée où il était
rapporteur de la commission
sa nomination le 2 octobre dernier au
poste laissé vacant par yvon bourges
cette nomination n'avait donc surpris
personne elle était en quelque sorte une
reconnaissance de ses compétences
gaulliste légitimistes il avait jusqu'au
bout en 74 soutenu la candidature de
jacques chaban delmas
quitte à devoir abandonner la scène
ministériel pendant quatre ans homme
discret mais ferme dévoué et travailleur
joël l'automne se faisaient une certaine
idée de la défense
il n'y a pas de priorité
si ce n'est celle de faire en sorte que
la politique décidée soit effectivement
appliquées et que nouveau est le
meilleur entraînement il faut que le
pays puisse avoir
l'armé ayant le maximum d'équipés cité
et s'il y avait un développement abonnés
c'est sans doute dans le domaine des
réserves mais sont sacrifiés quoi que ce
soit de ce kit
c'est ici à sablé-sur-sarthe que joël le
theule est mort la nuit dernière il
avait 50 ans depuis les messages ne
cessent d'affluer le président de la
république a dépêché son chef d'état
major particulier pour s'incliner devant
la dépouille du ministre
ce soir les hommes politiques mettent en
avant soit la fidélité au gaullisme
olivier guichard jacques chirac soit la
compétence le général bigeard le
socialiste charles hernu quant au
premier ministre il ya quelques instants
à orly il a confié son émotion
la mort de monsieur le theule est une
grande perte pour le gouvernement et
pour la france
monsieur le theule avet sur le plan
local et régional
une action extrêmement efficace il avait
un rôle important au parlement et il
avait été plusieurs fois dans les
gouvernements de la vème république
les obsèques de monsieur le theule
auront lieu après demain mardi
après-midi dans l'église de sablé sur
sarthe
c'est monsieur robert gallet ministre de
la coopération qui assurera l'intérim au
ministère de la défense mais bientôt il
faudra nommer un autre titulaire du
portefeuille de la défense
l'un des ministères claire du pays
quelques points mais je crois d'abord et
on s'étonne qu'il faut rappeler que sous
la vème république au niveau des
principes on n'a pas le souci de faire
des dosages lorsque l'on nomme des
ministres
car en effet le gouvernement n'est pas
l'émanation de l'assemblée nationale de
sa majorité des partis qui les
constituent mais l'autorité du
gouvernement procède de l'autorité du
président de la république qui nomme
lui-même le premier ministre et qui sur
la proposition de celui ci nommé
ministre
mais s'il est bien certain quand même
qu'il faut tenir compte des
susceptibilités qu'il faut tenir compte
également des équilibres et d'un certain
nombre de données
or s'agissant du poste qu'occupait
monsieur joël le theule la défense
nationale la défense faisant partie avec
l'indépendance nationale et puis les
institutions de cette fameuse trilogie
de l'héritage gaulliste
on note que sous la présidence de
monsieur giscard d'estaing comme sous
les présidents précédents
c'est toujours un gaulliste qui a occupé
ce poste et puis s'agissant de remplacer
monsieur le theule il faudra
vraisemblablement avoir recours à un
gaulliste que l'on dit légitimiste c'est
à dire en fait anti chiraquien lors il
n'est pas impensable d'ailleurs que ce
soit un ministre déjà en exercice qui
prennent le portefeuille de monsieur
l'auteur comme monsieur l'auteur lui
même avait changé de ministère pour
prendre la succession de monsieur
bourget dans tout cela je crois
il faudra tenir compte également d'une
certaine de susceptibilité ou
sensibilités de la majorité qu
actuellement connaît quelques
difficultés en bout de ces difficultés
monsieur de canut et président bdf qui
était aujourd'hui l'invité de nos
confrères de 1up numéro un club de la
presse a dû être interrogé sur ces
questions et bien oui lille a d'abord
réagi contre le rpr ou plus exactement
réagi
contre une déclaration de monsieur
charles pasqua selon lequel la
candidature de monsieur chirac devenait
indispensable
cette information sans m'avoir tout à
fait surpris me paraît étonnante
comment imaginer que l'ancien premier
ministre qui a été nommé choisi par le
président de la république puisse se
présenter contre celui aux rites ont
imaginé vous m'excuserez de prendre cet
exemple je le crois frappant que
monsieur debré qui avait sur l'algérie
une politique très déterminée est
différente il l'a lui même reconnu de
celle qu'a suivi finalement le général
de gaulle se saisissent de cette
divergence de vues pour ensuite
s'opposer au général de vous monsieur le
cas du m1 tiens si ce n'est ces
accusations du moins ses soupçons contre
certains dirigeants du rpr qui selon lui
seraient tentés de passer un pacte avec
le parti socialiste et quand on lui
demande si ses attaques contre jacques
chirac et contre le rpr ne vise pas
également à refaire l'unité de l'udf qui
était un peu secoué par les élections
légistatives monsieur lequel mais
reconnaît que ces élections législatives
partielles n'ont pas été bonnes pour
l'udf mais il affirme que l'udf est
toujours uni et solide que sa mission
c'est précisément de maintenir l'unité
dans la diversité
monsieur rené lévesque premier ministre
du québec commence en ce dimanche une
visite officielle de trois jours en
france
visite au cours de laquelle il
s'entretiendra notamment avec le chef de
l'état et avec monsieur bart qui l'a
accueilli à orly rené lévesque et
raymond barre doivent savoir ce soir un
tête à tête rapidement élargie à
plusieurs autres membres des deux
gouvernements
demain déjeuner à l'elysée puis rené
lévesque sera fait docteur honoris
les arts de l'université paris à la
sorbonne son séjour durera jusqu'à
mercredi
je rappellerai que rené lévesque avant
d'entrer dans la carrière politique plus
un très brillant journaliste de radio et
de télévision à paris et au canada et
demain à 20 heures au journal que
présentera patrick poivre d'arvor rené
lévesque sera son aide à propos du tchad
après le communiqué d'hier de l'elysée
et après les diverses réactions on
indique à paris de source autorisée
aujourd'hui que les informations du
quotidien libération selon lesquelles
les forces françaises action extérieure
interviendrait demain lundi là-bas ne
correspondent à aucune réalité ces
forces d'action extérieure comporte
toujours des unités prêtes à intervenir
sans grand préavis mais elles n'ont pas
reçu jusqu'à présent d'instruction
quelconque pour se mettre en état d'
alerte renforcée
il ya deux jours le prix de l'essence a
augmenté mais allons nous vers une
nouvelle augmentation dans un avenir
proche
c'est ce que l'on sera bientôt puisque
les pays de l'opep c'est à dire les pays
exportateurs de pétrole se réunissent à
partir de demain en indonésie à bali
philippe sassier plusieurs questions
d'abord pourquoi ben ali pourquoi si
loin sommes si loin pour nous tuer
d'abord c'est pas pour les danseuses de
ben ali très réputé ou pour le touriste
qui sont là bas on n'a pas encore
d'image sur cette ruine où il paraît que
le parti mais le pertamina pardon lodge
and hotel qui est un véritable paradis
transformer en fort chabrol qu'il ya des
automitrailleuses sur les plages et que
gainey videmment tout le monde a fui du
moins l'endroit ils vont se réunir alors
pourquoi effectivement ben ali bien vous
l'avez dit cela à bali appartient à
l'indonésie l'indonésie est membre de
l'opep et ben ali c'est effectivement
très loin du moyen-orient' très lien
très loin de ces tensions politiques et
des combats entre l'irak et l'iran qui
sont tous les deux membres de l'opep il
ne faut pas oublier que depuis le 31
octobre dernier
les irakiens détiennent monsieur javad
ton guyane qui est le ministre iranien
du pétrole
ils l'ont fait prisonnier ne faut pas
oublier non plus que l'iran et l'irak
vont se retrouver pour la première fois
autour d'une table depuis que leur
conflit ces messieurs le peuple quand il
parlait seulement des prix ou bien
aborderont-ils d'autres problèmes comme
par exemple la production alors la
situation politique où l'on vient
d'abord des très très rapidement revient
le plus d'amants assez difficile des
discussions techniques sur les prix du
pétrole
on a demandé notamment l'algérie et la
libye ont demandé aux irakiens et aux
iraniens de ne pas aborder leur affaire
de famille de ne pas trop parler de
politique autour de cette table alors y
aura deux sujets sains
l'approvisionnement du brut pour le
tiers-monde et deuxièmement leur
ajustement des prix du pétrole depuis le
1er janvier 1979 c'est à dire depuis
moins de deux ans les prix du pétrole
ont augmenté de plus de 60 de 160%
c'est plus de 160% aujourd'hui on parle
d'une hausse de l'ordre de 10% ce sont
les derniers bruits qui courent
actuellement dans les pays de l'opep
donc le prix du baril augmenterait de 3
à 4 dollars il n'ya pas semble-t-il de
risque à bali d'une véritable explosion
des prix depuis quelques temps sur les
marchés libres et bien les prix du
pétrole ont tendance à se stabiliser ce
qui donnerait pour nous français à la
pompe le prix de l'essence à combien
écouter s'il ya une augmentation
effectivement de l'ordre de 10% cela
signifierait vers le mois de février une
eau une hausse de 3 à 4 ou à 5 centimes
du prix du super mais tout dépendra ce
moment-là de la situation du franc par
rapport au dollar si le dollar continuer
à se ré évalué comme il le fait
actuellement et bien elle a host
pourrait être plus forte mais j'ai eu
écho au funk président du parti
communiste chinois a accepté de renoncer
à son poste sa décision résulte d'un
accord conclu au plus haut niveau des
instances du parti
je rappellerai que monsieur bako fang
avait déjà perdu ses fans et ses
fonctions de premier ministre et qui
était pratiquement absent de la vie
publique chinoise depuis de longues
semaines paires merdinyan 59 ans le
sourire malicieux et mystérieux la
démarche un peu lourde des paysans du
chan chee dont il était originaire voici
donc l'homme qui a succédé à mao et qui
devra abandonner son poste au cours de
l'année prochaine en fait cette
démission forcée le résultat d'un
véritable marché conclu au plus haut
niveau
on a volontairement gommer au cours du
procès de la bande des quatre
le rôle joué par wako fin durant la
révolution culturelle il était vice
premier ministre et ministre de la
sécurité lors de la terrible répression
des émeutes à pékin en avril 76
en échange le président du parti
communiste chinois accepte de
démissionner ainsi donc le conflit qui
l'opposait à son vice président tong yao
ping se soldent al'avantage de ce
dernier c'est du reste l'un de ses
protégés qui remplacera crois qu feng
son nom est déjà connu il s'appelle une
yaobang et il est âgé de 65 ans
roycod feng est donc la nouvelle victime
de la démonisation cours à pékin il
restera comme l'homme qui surgit dans
incognito il ya quatre ans a tout de
même réussi la transition de l'air de
repli de mao tsé toung à celle de la
chine de la compétition économique sur
nos écrans la photographie du magistrat
italien giovanni tour sont élevés à 24
soit par les brigades rouges
photo qui a été envoyée au quotidien de
rome république à monsieur dorsaux
apparaît les traits tirés devant un
drapeau portant l'étoile à cinq branches
des brigades rouges
il tient un écriteau avec un slogan
organiser la libération des prolétaires
prisonniers et il ya d'autres slogans
aussi monsieur d'urso est traité dans un
communiqué des brigades rouges de
bourreau de milliers de prôner terre des
pneus va et prison italienne
l'émotion est très profonde en italie où
l'on croyait que la tactique de tel
enlèvement n'était plus utilisé depuis
la sphère et la mort d'aldo moro avec
celui de secrétaire général du bcmc
kenya vient de rendre hommage à monsieur
brejnev grand ami de la pologne at il
dit le parlement polonais la diète se
réunit cette semaine pour examiner la
situation actuelle notant que la cfdt
envisage d'envoyer une délégation en
pologne juste avant la noël dans le but
de rencontrer les responsables du
syndicat solidarité mais les membres de
la délégation cfdt n'ont pas encore
obtenu leur visa pour varsovie le
candidat est le cardinal marty
archevêque de paris a invité les
chrétiens ce dimanche 14 décembre d'une
marche de la paix à prier pour le peuple
polonais qui vit dans l'angoissé
l'espérance ville dit dans son homélie
ce soir à notre dame le carnaval a
rappelé le thème retenu par le pape pour
le 1er janvier journée mondiale de la
paix pour servir la paix dit jean paul
ii respecte la liberté
la présidente du parti communiste
espagnol de l'arsb rory la célèbre
pasionaria symbole historique du
mouvement communiste mondiale a fêté
aujourd'hui à madrid son 85e
anniversaire et maintenant revenons en
france monsieur edmond maire serait père
général de la cfdt à france inter
aujourd'hui s'est abstenu de toute
critique à l'égard de la cgt mais non
pas l égard de monsieur bart visant je
cite monsieur mer le premier ministre ce
pub plus de son destin personnel que de
ce qui se passe dans la société
française hier soir à brest monsieur
marche est nette
plogoff réunion mouvementée parlement
houleuse le secrétaire général du pc a
dit le pays doit parvenir en 90 à
couvrir 60 % de ses besoins nationaux en
énergie par notre production nationale
il faut développer dans de bonnes
conditions de coude d'indépendance et de
sécurité le nucléaire ceux qui sont
contre le nucléaire sont ceux qui
restent mais lorsque des centaines de
fusée américaine s'installe aux
frontières de la france lors de ton
aujourd'hui les sections régionales des
syndicats de journalistes snj ljf cfdt
cgt protestent parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu
exercer leur travail hier un pur ennui
thing de ce marché dans les conditions
de sérénité qu'ils étaient en droit
d'attendre
et selon les syndicalistes les membres
du service d'ordre jusque là touch on
aura du pc ont été particulièrement
déplaisants à l'égard de nos confrères
la baisse de la baguette de pain fait si
je puis dire tache d'huile dans un
hypermarché de saint-avold en moselle la
baguette de 200 grammes sera vendu dès
demain moins d'un franc et à partir de
mardi en haute-loire on la trouvera un
frein à yssingeaux et à monistrol sur
loire dans le département de l'hérault
un drame de la démence à balaruc les
bains
un homme de 35 ans a tué d'un coup de
carabine sa femme leurs enfants
puis il s'est fait justice vient dans le
monde trouble et douloureux déchiré où
nous vivons
faut-il s'abandonner à la certitude du
pire les pessimistes vous diront que oui
que ça craque de toutes parts berthe
loix qu'ils ont tort
et vous le verrez bien demain soir à
20h35 vous en paierez le cabba chez
l'équipe centaines de vous présenteront
en direct du musée de l'homme à paris
une émission question de temps
exceptionnel les raisons d'espérer car
il y en a et de nombreuses ainsi serez
liane la figure lumineuse de l'ouganda
le syndicaliste polonais lech walesa
avec tout ce qu'il représente d'espoir
pour ses compatriotes norbert se gare et
son combat contre le cancer qui donne
confiance à d'autres malades en
aquitaine un village tout entier qui se
mobilisent contre le chômage et d'autres
exemples encore demain soir 20h35
aussitôt après le journal télévisé une
émission qui sera réalisée en direct par
roger bélair et ce soir georges leclercq
pour symboliser l'espoir a choisi la
jeunesse non pas une jeunesse craintive
aux désespérés mais une jeunesse capable
d' inventions et plein d'espoir devant
l'afflux
un disque images contenant un film une
disquette d'ordinateurs contenant un
programme informatique
voici les deux armes d'alexandre raineau
lauréat du prix philips qui vient juste
d'avoir 15 ans avec ses deux armes et
bien sûr le matériel qui va avec
alexandra réaliser une invention
fantastique que les techniciens les plus
qualifiés jugeaient impossible avant
c'est la connexion d'un lecteur de vidéo
disque qui avait été conçu pour
visualiser des films un ordinateur et là
j'ai pris comme exemple fini dents de la
mer que j'ai composées en différents
thèmes de cinéma personnage expression
effet de cinéma on peut accéder à des
séquences voit des images qui sont dans
le lecteur par ces mots clés personnage
égal 1 donc la pluie et après on a la
liste des personnages que j'ai à perte
auriez sûr j'ai pas répertorié tous les
personnages qui sont stockés sur le
vidéo disque parce que mon étude n'était
pas ce film les dents de la mer mais
plutôt sur le vidéo disque l'intérêt du
losc en actions ce qui est pas destiné à
un usage précis on peut l'utiliser
pouvoir s'occuper 10 pour la formation
mais on peut aussi très bien l'utiliser
pour toute formation chez soi et pour
l'enseignement la formation dans les
domaines très divers c'est à dire
qu'avec le même appareil
on peut très bien avoir une encyclopédie
mais tout aussi avoir des recettes de
cuisine suffirait de changer de disque
c'est ça si un jour l'invention
d'alexandre arrive chez vous ce sera en
partie grâce aussi à bruno lussato
professeur au conservatoire national des
arts et métiers le cnam
c'est lui qui a recueilli alexandre
raineau lorsque ces professeurs de lycée
l'on exclut de la troisième notamment
pour manque d'imagination et c'est lui
qui l'orienté vers le vidéo disque
alexandre s'est initié en quelques mois
à l'informatique avec les professeurs du
cnam cela ne l'empêchent pas de préparer
son bac en auditeur libre
il passera le français cette année et le
bac c'est l'année prochaine
quand on lui demande ce qu'il compte
faire après alexandre raineau à une
réponse étonnante tout à fait à la
mesure de l'évolution des techniques
qu'ils manient après on voit que
continuer mes études dans quelle branche
biomasse faty que là dessus et après
peut-être informatique mais il est
difficile de définir une branche précise
une orientation précise pourquoi on que
déjà en deux ans espace plein de choses
et que donc ce n'est pas difficile en
ces temps de définir précisément ce
qu'on veut c'est [ __ ] essie jaïn
d'ailleurs servent ensuite
d'entraînement pour tous les autres qui
suivent
c'est à dire ça élève le niveau je dois
avouer qu'un garçon comme raynaud loin
de diminuer les zooms ils ont tous
étudiants enfin la valeur de mesut
étudiants leur a donnée justement des
raisons d'espérer
et il faut bien le dire leur donner
envie de compétition
pour marc raynaud qui a été en
définitive profitable à tous tous les
jeunes sont un peu différents mais qu'
il ya une certaine angoisse du futur qui
est un peu capot tout le monde vous avez
l'angoissent du futur oui il est acté
oui par quel côté eh bien je tourne
société bouge tellement que ce qui va
arriver demain
malgré son angoisse du futur alexandre
représente selon nous au moins trois
espoirs celui de l'élève inadapté au
lycée et qui pourtant réussi celui des
gens qui voient le monde change et trop
vite pour eux mais qu'ils réalisent que
leurs enfants eux sauront le comprendre
et enfin celui des jeunes qui ne savent
pas vers quoi se tourner et qui voit de
nouvelles voies tracées
par d'aussi jeunes que monsieur le cas
ministre de la culture et de la
communication a clôturé aujourd'hui à
falaise l'année du patrimoine qu'il
avait ouverte le 1er janvier arc et
senans dans le doubs le ministre
dressant un bilan de l'année du
patrimoine a dit que les opérations de
sensibilisation du public avait connu un
très grand succès ainsi la fréquentation
des musées monuments historiques a
augmenté de 40%
c'était au grand palais à paris une
exposition d'art super quelques-unes des
plus belles acquisitions des musées
nationaux depuis cinq ans et notamment à
la suite de dons et de legs jean
philippe llech a expliqué louis doucet
la manière dont s'est évertué cet
enrichissement de notre patrimoine
artistique
c'est le sens civ art des plus célèbres
diamant de la couronne depuis le 16e
siècle après divers avatars il a enfin
réintégrer la france en 1976
un exemple entre autres des merveilles
acquise depuis cinq ans est entré dans
les collections nationales
je crois en effet qu'en cinq ans les
procédures qui existent pour préserver
le patrimoine français ont mis en place
l'équivalent d'un musée j'ai beaucoup de
villes moyennes
par exemple je dirais sur le continent
américain qui ne présentent pas
diversité des oeuvres et la qualité de
celles qui sont réunis là ensuite toutes
ces oeuvres vont être placés dans des
musées correspondant leur vocation par
exemple les grands souvenirs
napoléoniens qui sont là bien ils vont
être installés dans le musée napoléon
créé à fontainebleau
les très grands tableaux
impressionnistes la danse à la vive la
danse à la campagne de renoir vont aller
au musée d'orsay
les tableaux par exemple qui sont le
philippe de champaigne le merveilleux
portrait puis le jean peine ou le la
tour rend à léo lourd donc ensuite tout
ceci sera éclatée c'est donc aussi une
occasion unique pour les français de
voir en rassembler pendant un instant
ses heures c'est fou ce qu'on peut
encore trouver à droite à gauche et que
l'on ne soupçonne pas comme ça comment
seront saisis à leur écoute et yapi yapi
joly à trois procédures
il y en a une d'abord qui consiste à
acquérir si on achète il ya des crédits
ministère de la culture il ya notamment
les crédits du fonds du patrimoine des
crédits nouveaux qui permettent
d'acquérir des oeufs et le vent acquis
un certain nombre de droits acquis par
un tableau de fragonard le verrouille
fragonard une acquisition
il ya d'autres par des donations et les
donateurs sont encore très nombreux en
france ceci est très important
par exemple certains des plus grands
souvenirs napoléoniens l'épée de
frédéric ii le glaive du premier consul
ou par exemple les meubles la collection
en gros carven ont été donnés donné à
l'état par les deux nattes et puis il y
a cette nouvelle procédure qui est celle
du paiement des droits de succession par
la remise d'oeuvre d'art qui nous a
permis de recevoir par exemple
l'occasion de la succession picasso plus
de 300 tableaux de picasso
j'ajoute que la france a le meilleur
système du monde de protection de son
patrimoine puisque nous sommes l'un des
seuls pays à disposer la possibilité
d'interdire la sortie d'une oeuvre d'art
et nous avons le droit de l'acquérir à
sa valeur déclarée en douane
mais toutes ces heures sont connus
répertoriés n'y a pas deux de découverte
les chefs-d'oeuvre non il n'y a pas de
découverte de shed sauf un cas
particulier qui est en effet la
quatrième source
l'enrichissement du patrimoine national
qui sur les découvertes archéologiques
vous savez qu'il existe en france vingt
mille sites archéologiques qui ont été
fouillés
il y en a vraisemblablement 200 milles
qui sont intéressants il y a donc encore
de belles découvertes à faire pour cette
belle exposition c'est de bel esprit le
dernier dimanche d'auteuil s'est
déroulée sous la pluie l'arrivée du
tiercé à venelles résultats suivants
cache ni lé prince enfants tous deux
entraînés par le mans series mersen
c'est à dire 5 3 7 pierrette brès levé
ce tiercé dans l'eure
première fois en cinq chevaux seulement
voici l'arrivée les chevaux vont sauter
de l'avant dernier obstacle me tuer bien
à gauche de l'écran cash mille casaque
orange manche bleus au centre de l'écran
série marpen dont le jeu qu'est porte
une casaque jaune et vert et à droite
près dé trend complètement à droite de
l'écran prince enfants kazakh s'appelait
jaune et noir toc rouge la lutte entre
les deux entre les trois chevaux est
très très dur et c'est seulement par une
courte tête qu'à gauche cache ni lé
spécialiste du terrain lourd va battre
de l'autre côté de la piste 1 5 ans et
cachetée les montées par du gaz des deux
premiers sont entraînés par la main 3e
série marten elle les jeunes chevaux un
jeune cheval de quatre ans a précédé
donc saisi pour leur première rencontre
maintenant les rapports du tiercé
s'inscrivent sur votre écran c'est pour
5 francs 5 187 50 dans un ordre
différent 117,50 ça me fais pas beaucoup
mais je suppose que si vous étiez avec
nous hier soir vous l'avez touché sport
toujours champion de france de football
le point après le match nul de
saint-etienne contre nancy et le
classement de la première division
quelques images d'auxerre paris saint
germain c'est auxerre qui l'a emporté
par 3 à 2 face au psg qui a réalisé son
plus mauvais match à ce stade de la
saison pourtant le premier but que vous
allez voir est à mettre au crédit des
parisiens grâce à tokyo mais auxerre se
reprendra et mérite un grand bravo
les résultats maintenant chassé croisé
en tête de ce championnat de france
nantes victorieux à l'extérieur prend le
fauteuil de leader à saint-etienne qui a
tout de même réussi le match nul à nancy
c'était la 22e journée auxerre et nantes
sont les seuls à gagner à l'extérieur
peu de buts au cours de ce week-end et
beaucoup de matches nuls 5 sur 10 lyon
gagne devant la lanterne rouge 1 points
d'avance pour nantes / saint-etienne le
psg lyon compte un match de retard à
noter nîmes occupe une bien mauvaise
posture le titre se jouera entre nantes
et saint-etienne car derrière outre
bordeaux
les clubs ne suis guère la progression
des leaders jean christophe simond du
vésinet a conservé son titre de champion
de france de patinage artistique et à
lyon les blancs chez les rouges ont
beaucoup roulé tous ces jours ci il
s'agissait du championnat d'europe de
billard au 47,2 à première vue se lavait
d'ésotérique et mystérieux mais il
s'agit en réalité de quelque chose
d'agréable à kherbet et à pratiquer vous
allez voir ça roule très bien
magie du billard lumière couleur douceur
le principe du jeu est de toucher avec
une bille blanche les deux billes de
l'adversaire et de réaliser ensuite le
plus de points possibles ce jeu à la
partie libre est presque trop facile
pour des joueurs de niveau international
qui sont capables de conduire les trois
billes sur le tour du billard pour
réaliser des séries impressionnantes de
2 3 à 4000 points pour rendre le jeu
plus spectaculaire et plus difficile le
billard a été partagé en neuf surface
appelé cadre délimité par des lignes
parallèles aux bandes est située à 47 cm
de ces dernières c'est la première
partie de l'explication du cadre 47 2 la
seconde nous a donnés par francis
connesson
champion du monde
ici vous voyez la vie du joueur ne
compte pas qu'elle soit entrée dans le
cac vous sorti du cadre n'a aucune
importance
seul importe les deux but adverse ici le
lard mitran on fera entrer dans ce cas
là le joueur aura la permission de faire
un point l'arbite annoncera maintenant 2
dans le cadre et il faut al'annonce de
dedans que le joueur sorte une des 2 be
adverse
wiesen beck le champion d'europe le
voici en pleine réflexion
il doit calculer chaque point chaque
parcours suivis par les billes afin de
les garder le plus group est possible
mais réfléchir ne suffit pas sans une
parfaite maîtrise technique tout point
pensée n'est pas facilement réalisable
tout la technique est dans le dosage des
effets l'intensité et la précision de la
frappe de billes l'apprentissage de
cette technique nécessite un
entraînement poussé
ça commence par quelques années et
disons journellement il faut ensuite
ramené de 6 à 8 alors le billard pour
vous c'est un jeu c'est un sport où
c'est un honneur pour moi c'est à la
fois un art au niveau de la compétition
c'est obligatoirement un sport et s'il
s'agit de confronter des techniques
différentes et devient sportif par ce
fait même de la qualité la plus
importante prolongement demi-heure la
qualité essentielle du vent dans sa
mémoire visuelle
rassurez-vous le joueur de billard n'est
pas un robot qui répète inlassablement à
ce stade de la compétition c'est souvent
l'équilibré nerveux qui fait la
différence
le brouillard est interrompue durant
toute la matinée de ce dimanche de
trafic à marseille marignane et
plusieurs vols ont dû être détournés
vers nîmes provenance de paris de corse
d'afrique du nord d'où le retard des
voyageurs peut être que vous attendiez
demain le temps sera variable sur la
moitié nord ouest du pays est couvert
avec free ou neige des alpes à la
franche comté
seules les régions méditerranéennes et
la corse bénéficieront de quelques
éclaircies mais il y aura mistral et
tramontane sur la manche les vents
tourneront au nord-ouest et frison la
tempête
les températures baisseront de 3 à 4
degrés notre édition est terminée vers
23 heures c'est gérard holtz qui vous
présentera les dernières informations de
la journée demain antenne de midi et
puis le soir c'est rené lévesque premier
ministre du québec qui sera l'invité de
patrick poivre d'arvor au journal de 20
heures et aussitôt après le journal de
20 heures la grande émission qui est
vous permettra de vous revoir et
l'approfondir toutes les raisons qu'il
ya d'espérer un question de temps
exceptionnel
bonsoir merci
à